[Musique]
une grande tente érigée sous un arbre au
beau milieu d'un champ du petit village
de nandy symbole d'espoir et de
changement
des dizaines de villageois commencent à
arriver le mot s'est passé
l'organisme buzz women offre une
formation gratuite pour devenir
indépendante et se sortir de la pauvreté
gendre est venue avec sa fille de 9 ans
mère de famille n'effectue que de menus
travaux dans le village l'espère
apprendre comment devenir autonomes
financièrement afin de pouvoir fonder sa
propre entreprise de transport je ne
veux plus gaspiller mon temps et mon
énergie dit elle l'organisme buzz web n
existe depuis neuf ans dans le sud de
l'inde
deux cent mille villageoises ont été
formés grâce à ces ateliers mobiles
la quasi totalité d'entre elles ont pu
arrêter d'emprunter de l'argent à leur
conjoint ou à leurs familles et une
femme sur cinq a même démarrer sa propre
entreprise
la fondatrice de l'organisme est
accueilli avec tous les honneurs partout
où elle va elle espère pouvoir aider 10
millions d'indiennes à retrouver
l'estimé de soi et la confiance en elle
d'ici 2030 à 42 watts kane mitchell
une des participantes sera choisi pour
assurer un suivi à l'atelier au cours
des deux à trois prochaines années
une démarche cruciale dans ces villages
où les occasions d'emploi sont rares
encore plus pour les femmes et le
responsable it is family and me
déportais l'émancipation des femmes
passe également par la formation et les
groupes de soutien dans les grandes
villes indiennes comme mumbai les
activités génératrices d'emplois les
aide à développer leur autonomie
[Musique]
ici les femmes des cours cous et
transforme de vieux sarir vêtements
indiens traditionnels 6 harry devienne
une panoplie d'objets --des habillés à
la mode
vendu ensuite en europe toutes celles
qui travaillent dans l'entreprise
sociale un waza ari
ils sont venus en quête de dignité et de
respect un geste courageux pour ces
femmes issus des villages défavorisés
marié à un jeune âge est déménagée à
mumbai poursuivre leur mari bon nombre
d'entre elles était battu il n'avait
même pas le droit de sortir de chez elle
mutuellement acceptable bail de family
même aux origines aux abords des deux
monstres des mers orthodoxe des travaux
menés to please come by des données avec
prudence du col d'aitana des notes les
prêtres l'équilibré
rita à 23 ans elle est originaire d'un
village dans le nord de l'aisne sa
famille trop pauvres pour payer ses
cours la retirer de l'école à 14 ans
sans pour autant lui donner le droit de
travailler elle est finalement arrivée
dans cet atelier il y a deux ans jusqu'à
récemment elle était le seul gagne-pain
de sa famille elle se sent aujourd'hui
confiante et motivée elle ose même
parfois se balader seul dans les rues de
mumbai
comme son rêve de poursuivre ses études
s'est évanoui elle espère simplement
pouvoir continuer à travailler
originaire de calcutta sans guitare
quitté l'école à 16 ans quand ses
parents non mariés et les couturières
depuis cinq ans on a commenté n'est pas
pour que ses trois enfants 1 e plus
aller à l'école
elle peut aussi payer les médicaments de
son mari qui lui ne peut pas travailler
en raison d'ennuis grave à l'estomac
son rêve voir son fils de 3 ans
décrocher un bon emploi pour qu'ils
puissent ils soutenir elle et son mari
dans leurs vieux jours
[Musique]
près de 170 femmes ont travaillé dans
cette ong fondée il ya huit ans elle
gagne un dollar de l'heure un montant
intéressant en inde
elle bénéficie aussi d'une assurance
médicale et d'un programme d'elle pour
les frais de scolarité
une goutte d'eau dans un océan
d'injustice envers les femmes ont un job
à 6 bender et n'a pas le bon many many
many jon brion ou lynch dog is born to
be over et longue journée for every
à nandy tiendra termine la formation
remplie d'espoir et là encore en tête
sont modestes projet d'entrepreneuriat
mais j'ai aussi appris que je dois me
développer et m'épanouir comme personne
dit elle
elle rentre à la maison convaincu
qu'elle pourrait offrir un avenir
meilleur à sa fille il si philippe
leblanc au canada non dits en inde